what does that mean to say that a story
is better than the real we love that
line
stories better than the real because one
of the things that we've figured out is
in a story is a thing it's different
than real life and I mean you could you
could talk about that for 10 years you
know what does that mean especially in
the you know in the realistic filmmaking
you know phase that you know we're
seeing especially the Indies but but the
truth is that a story isn't real life
and in some ways something's a story in
every way in which it's not real life
right so in real life people are mainly
mysterious to us they we don't know why
they do what they do we don't have
access to their motivations story is not
like that we do have access to their
motivations we do know what's driving
them so watching a story you get a
little surge of guilty pleasure because
it gives you something real life cannot
legitimately give you that you have no
right to want in real life so if a movie
is when we read a script if it doesn't
give that access if it doesn't clarify
the motives of the character really what
they want and what they need and what's
driving them it's a bad story because
that's one of the things that people
expect and story that they're going for
is access you know emotional access and
another way that story is better than
the real is that the the settings are
more interesting than our everyday lives
you know we don't go to the movies to
watch somebody you know in the bathroom
for an hour getting ready for work you
know that's that's our everyday mundane
life we go to the movies to see
beautiful landscapes and beautiful
vistas and to see quirky worlds and
quirky arenas that are more interesting
than our everyday world and similarly we
look the characters in movies we like
them because there is something just a
little bit there they're like us but
they're just a little bit better than us
and and that's the that's the quality of
a hero is
somebody who aspires to do the things
that we could grow up to do that are
within reach of what we could do but are
just you know they're just going a
little bit more beyond what we might be
doing in everyday life another way
stories are better than the real is that
they're structured around a theme
they're structured around some universal
truth about human life and this is not
your real life right your real life if I
say to you how did you learn you know
what's some big lesson you learned and
you say to me well I learned that it's
important to be truthful I learned this
you know by the time I was thirty that I
wasn't gonna lie anymore it's like okay
so that means you probably had a
thousand little incidents from the time
you were four and started talking where
you started to learn when I lie I get in
trouble you know and having to juggle
storytelling and you know and all of
this stuff and so finally at the age of
thirty you go knowing I'm not gonna lie
anymore right but it's this cumulative
thing that well in a movie or in a story
this happens in two hours there we where
you take out all the other lessons that
people are learning and you say we're
just gonna look at how Luke learned that
he needs to trust the force right you
know in storage we're not gonna look at
all Luke's other problems that that that
he's a slob or he has issues with women
or that he's you know he's got jealousy
stuff no we're just gonna hone in on
that so it's a very unnatural structured
around a theme experience so when we
read a screenplay that it just seems to
be all over the place we say people this
isn't gonna work as a story because the
audience doesn't get what are we talking
about here what is this about and that's
one of the big notes that we end up
giving all the time that the writer
hasn't been able to really say this
story is about this and so I'm gonna
eliminate everything that isn't about
that you know the big idea that writers
sometimes just never made that choice
and so that you stand back from the
screenplay and you say I don't know what
this comes down to in the end I don't
know what this is really about so a
story is better than real life because
it gives us it really cuts out
everything that isn't on your
Universal truth and story also has a
resolution unlike real life where it
seems like we're always waiting for our
act 3 to happen we often don't know what
what resolutions are going to be
happening for us in our everyday world
but in a story it needs to resolve and
that that resolution needs to be
satisfying and it's the satisfaction
that comes from that resolution that
makes that story better than what we
normally go through in life and then on
top of that all the little elements of
story are better than real life so
dialogue you know in in to write a good
line of dialogue sometimes it'll take me
three weeks and then ten drafts later
I'm still tweaking that that come back
think about it as you have a fight with
your friend and then you sit there in
the shower kind of replaying that and
you keep coming up that line like that's
what movies are that the writer has
gotten that perfect response so you have
this perfect back-and-forth repartee
that real life never has if any if
people in real life talk the way they do
in the movies these will be crazy people
you know but in the movies it's okay
it's expected you know in in
storytelling so the idea of of
everything being honed to be
entertaining to be compelling to be a
feast it's it's a story is a feast as
opposed to just running through the
frigerator open the door and grab a few
things that's real life right but a
story is a feast and so that that as we
say to our writers you know your your
what you've done here just isn't
feasting enough it's just not better
enough than people's real life and you
know we always quote this one line when
the cinema verite movement was going
through the 50s everybody was trying to
do some realism realism realism mainly
coming out of Europe because they did
have any money but Hitchcock the Great
Master said you know some people want
movies to be a slice of life I want two
movies to be a slice of cake yeah and
there it is you know that movie is
better than the real and that it's a
slice of cake and and if and if it's we
don't see it on the screen and the the
paper because you're trying too much to
be great
and real then it's like why would
anybody want to do this and and then the
last thing I would say to is that your
movie needs to be at least as good as
the real but it needs to be better than
the real so in other words it can't be
such that people watch this movie and go
wow people don't talk like that that
would never happen this is so boring
it's like yeah all right you know so
those are signs that the script isn't
working that your movie as and even as
good as the real so you got a 10 you got
to get to the real and then you got to
push it and be better than the real
you